hey guys I'm back in this video we're
gonna talk about the five critical
ketosis tips now I've done a lot of
videos in ketosis and some of you are
new some of you have been to my channel
for a long time so I'm going to put some
more links down below so you can get
caught up but these are like really
important tips there's a lot of ways to
do it incorrectly and there is a right
way to do it these are the the correct
ways okay so what happens when you do a
ketosis diet it's like taking a diuretic
you're gonna dump a lot of fluid through
the body because when you've been you
were burning sugar fuel you were
retaining fluid and now we're cutting up
the sugar you're going to dump a lot of
food this is why some people can lose
like 10 pounds in a week
that's not fat that's fluid and with the
fluid comes the elimination of
electrolytes like potassium and
magnesium so we must put that back and a
lot of times people need to add more
electrolytes with more fluid so I'm not
against drinking more water especially
if you don't overdo it but we need to
put that fluid back make mental note of
this one right here now waste
elimination if you get constipated on
this program you have to handle that
because what happens is the toxins in
the fat cell that's stored in there are
also released when you burn this fat so
if you don't have a good elimination
system the gallbladder is working the
liver and your get constipated that is
it's going to back up to the thyroid you
know you get the keto rash create a lot
of problems so there's two situations
one if you were constipated before doing
this program and you're still
constipated it's okay to take an herbal
laxative in the meantime just to get
things going that's more important than
thinking you're going to be addicted to
a laxative or if you became constipated
on this program that means that either
you're you can't digest the kale or the
types of vegetables or the fibers and
the vegetables so switch it up go back
to so maybe some romaine lettuce as
compared to some of the cruciferous and
add fermented vegetables and if you even
need maybe a mild laxative tea like a
slippery elm bark smooth move tea go
ahead and do it very very important to
get that elimination going good and I
also like to use symptoms that
indication to see what
wrong like for example when you switch
from sugar burning to fat burning a lot
of times you might get tired in the
transition that means that your body is
utilizing more B vitamins it's using
more sodium so you better start putting
back in the B vitamins if you get tired
or flu-like symptoms and some sea salt I
like to use nutritional yeast okay so
that's a that's very very important now
the other thing is you want to watch
watch your fat you know some people they
get this oh they get this program oh I
can start eating tons and tons of fat
they start overdoing it their livers not
up to digesting that their gallbladder
is getting blown out they get right
shoulder pain they get the keto rash all
these issues because they're not used to
digesting all this fat and if that
happens you need some gall bladder like
purified bile salts but I would go a
little lighter with the fats to see if
you can digest them so your gall bladder
can adapt to that we need sunsets but we
don't want to overdo it okay okay then
we get to number five which is the
quality food you just realize that every
single calorie of food that you put in
your body is replacing your body parts
okay so the last thing you want to end
up is looking like a crackhead right
yeah so to avoid that to avoid looking
very unhealthy as you lose weight you
want to have grass-fed foods like
grass-fed animal meats things like that
you want organic Wow caught fish
pasture-raised eggs okay so if you want
to avoid looking like a crackhead and
you want to look healthy go ahead and
put the quality back in and put your
comments below I'll talk to you soon